[Musique]
il est 8 heures 17 à batna d'europe 1
mathieu belliard votre invité sonia
mabrouk c'est le président par intérim
du parti des républicains jean leonetti
ancien ministre mais également maire lr
d'antibes juan les pins
bonjour jean leonetti bonjour je
m'adresse ce matin au maire que vous
êtes pour évoquer la situation d'un élu
alors ce n'est pas un maire qui passe
dans les médias nous n'avons à ma
connaissance jamais parler de lui
écoutez tu vas prendre un coup de fusil
tué visé est dans une autre lettre
choisis ton cercueil ça fait froid dans
le dos c'est un peu dommage d'arrêter un
mandat sur ces faits et je suis et moi
je suis après ce but je pense surtout
aux berges du xingu je ne voulais pas
faire subir à ma famille ce qu'olmert de
signes a fait subir à sa famille sans
vouloir ça fait 36 ans que régis
vallienne exerce avec passion et
abnégation son mandat de maire à prier
l'aiguillé dans la sarthe trois
courriers de menaces de mort l'ont
décidé à ne pas se représenter
ma mère qui abandonne ses la république
hercules la république elle est incarnée
par les maires parce que c'est des élus
de proximité qui tire une légitimité
d'une campagne de proximité généralement
avec un projet pour leur cité pour leur
village et donc qu'on joue aujourd'hui
on voit un découragement
ce découragement à mon avis il est
double d'abord parce que il ya une
violence une exigence quelquefois et
plus particulièrement d'ailleurs dans
les petites communes que dans les
grandes communes parce que le maire de
la grande commune il est relativement
protégé alors que l'autre et est
directement à apporter d'engueulades
comme le dit gérard larcher
l'engueulade est passé à la menace
physique et puis le deuxième point c'est
que il est maire en été et plus
particulièrement les maires ruraux ont
été particulièrement méprisé parle pas
le pouvoir
on a à considérer finalement ne faisait
pas de lien entre les deux arguments que
vous me présenter je fais pas de lien
mais
lorsque le maire se heurte à à des
règlements de plus en plus complexes à
des responsabilités de plus en plus
lourde qu'on lui dit qu'il est
responsable de tous de l'arbre qui tombe
de la manifestation qui se passe le soir
et qui entraîne un blessé et que
finalement il se sent peu soutenu par le
gouvernement et par l'état bien il est
il est dans ce no man's land dans lequel
il est coincé entre des revendications
quelquefois légitime d'ailleurs de ses
concitoyens et le silence méprisant du
pouvoir vous vous dites silence
méprisant du pouvoir un projet de loi
est attendu justement pour protéger les
élus mieux définir leurs prérogatives
d'ailleurs le ministre qui le portent
sébastien lecornu sera notre invité
demain
qu'est ce que vous lui demandez
précisément s'il y avait une mesure s'il
y avait une mesure c'est que l'état soit
à la hauteur de la mission qui est la
sienne
c'est un peuple hague alors je vais vous
dire les choses plus précisément que par
exemple quand on vous dit on a plus de
policiers parce qu'ils sont tous au g7
et que donc le feu d'artifice qui va
être retirée tel jour à telle heure eh
bien on n'a pas les moyens d'assurer la
sécurité alors que ans et on se souvient
que à nice le 14 juillet il ya eu un
attentat terroriste
qu'est ce que vous faites vous supprimez
le feu d'artifice ou bien vous assumez
avec les forces de police qui a la
responsabilité d'assumer la mission
donc voilà c'est dans ces moments là qu
est malgré tout tout l'engagement qu'ont
les préfets ou les policiers on voit
bien que y'a un moment il ya un divorce
doute que l'exécutif que le gouvernement
défende mère évidemment et les élus
donc j'en doute oui oui c'est bien tout
âge et 1,12 je pense qu'il faut dire
morts dans les geôles mais que dans les
actes on a beaucoup considéré jusqu au
gilet jaune jusqu'à cette situation où
on a changé de ton et pas forcément
d'action le gouvernement et en
particulier le président de la
république a considéré pendant longtemps
que les territoires les maires
c'était pas sa préoccupation principale
je ne sais pas si vous avez écouté
europe 1 ce matin les précédents jours
information europe1 lemesle président de
la république et macro sera présent il
ouvrira le prochain congrès de maires y
voyez un signe une attention
particulière baj higuain c'est une
particulier c'est que les municipales
sont pas loin
tout le monde y compris pour vous prier
oui moi je veux dire que la république
est en marche n'a pas d'ancrage
territorial et la pomiculture erreur à
mon avis avec cette situation comme
qu'il a développée vis-à-vis des mers où
il y avait à la fois une partie de
séduction je t'invite on en discute et
puis une partie de menaces rappelez-vous
la phrase terrible de boyer qui avaient
dit les mères qui seront pas investis
par la république en marche seront les
ennemis du président m d une tension à
l'intérieur de merde il a reculé depuis
en tous les cas il n'a wimille 1re fort
bien ce que je dis mais le président
aussi à reculer
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites vous
avez parlé du ton jean leonetti vous
avez remarqué que sur les autres
réformes et notamment la mère des
batailles les retraites vous entendez
cette petite musique de rentrer
consultation concertation bref le
président écoute et ne bouscule pas bah
le projet président recule recule bas
bien sûr je veux dire hercules et
surtout il est l'élu de la vérité
iramuno des faudra dire la vérité aux
français sur les retraites quelle est la
vérité la vérité ce qui vous travailler
plus longtemps
voilà après qu'on trouve des modalités
de plus de justice l'avait vous leviez
en deux on l'a dit a longtemps je suis
beau final que c'est la droite car
mamcafé les réformes des retraites
si la droite françois fillon nicolas
sarkozy n'avait pas fait la réforme des
retraites en soit aujourd'hui dans un
déséquilibre majeur
est ce que vous vous rappelez une seule
fois que la gauche afin qu'une réforme
des retraites pour justement continuer
cette solidarité intergénérationnelle
jamais il ne va pas bien devenu de
consulter d'associer tout le monde est
de prendre son temps sur cette délicate
réforme
le problème dans l'ordre de la
consultation c'est ce qui est important
c'est de savoir qu'est ce qu'on en tire
ont fait une grande consultation les
états généraux qui d'ailleurs la loi sur
le
la bioéthique et ensuite on n'en tient
pas compte on fait un grand débat que
plutôt un monologue et ensuite on en
décide tout seul donc attention la
concertation pour qu'elles pour que le
citoyen respecte la concertation et les
maires le savent bien il faut qu'à la
fin de la concertation en tiennent
compte de ce qu'ils ont dit vous avez
parlé de la bioéthique jean leonetti la
mention mais reimer inscrits sur l'acte
de naissance des enfants de couples de
femmes
est-ce que c'est du bon sens est-ce que
c'est logique dont ceux sus de mensonge
institutionnel on y songe institutions
oui on est deux hommes et d'une femme
tout le monde le sait et vous avez là
une volonté de gommer quelconque
paternité
oui mais bien sûr que le fait de dire
que on peut avoir un enfant sans père ça
gomme la paternité après on l'assumons
l'assument pas mais le dire par exemple
comme agnès buzyn l'a dit que ça n'est
pas un débat éthique c'est quoi alors un
débat éthique un débat éthique sûr on
s'interroge sur les avantages des
inconvénients les inventer de pensée de
la science
la tante de la société c'est ça un vrai
débat à partir du moment où on distinct
marqueur parce que le président l'a
promis nous et pourtant qui a comme un
biais idéologique introduit par le
gouvernement des vingt biais idéologique
la preuve il ya un mensonge voilà quand
on dit la pma pour tout ça ne touche que
l'amour entre deux femmes
alors là on dit mais bien sûr de femmes
peuvent s'aimer et elles auront
légitimement qui va aimer l'enfant
qu'ils veulent éduquer qui va
l'accompagner qui va le protéger tout au
long de cette sas et je dirais que c'est
pas la question de qui c'est la question
de l'enfant est ce que l'enfant a des
droits ou est-ce qu'on a un droit à
l'enfant
et vous avez vu la subtilité qui montre
bien la fragilité de la position c'est
qu'on va dire qu'il ya une mère
principal il y en a une qui va être
principal c'est celle qui aura accouché
et l'autre et les quoi elle est maire en
numéro 2
les maires accessoires elle est mère de
substitution c'est un mensonge en tous
les cas le débat en tout cas c'est le
mensonge qui existe c'est d'avoir dit il
n'y a aucun lien entre la pma pour toute
la filiation mais de se rendre compte
qu'il ya un lien avec la filiale jean
leonetti la rentrée a sonné pour tout le
monde y compris pour votre party les
républicains est ce que le docteur
leonetti on vous la fait souvent connaît
le remède le remède miracle pour faire
repartir l'électrocardiogramme plat
raplapla la droite
vous savez il ya un moment où il faut
voilà ou bien en accompagnement en enfin
l'accompagnement
je dirais palliatifs et on accompagne le
déclin ou bien on rompt décide de
réanimer et je pense que on est au stade
où on n'a plus le choix
c'est la réanimation et la réanimation
sur des fondamentaux fort sur nos
valeurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle je veux qu
à la fois on vote pour un président mais
que en même temps au nez la capacité de
dire et qui nous sommes jallet mais
est-ce que vous reconnaissez que l'un
des meilleurs atouts des manuels macron
sait qui c'est vous c'est l'opposition
hall b quand on a une opposition comme
ça pas besoin
non c'est à dire c'est pas tellement
qu'on soit mauvais c'est koné absent
donc c'est ici il suffirait d'être
présent de ne pas dire les choses avec
violence est ce que je dis aujourd'hui
ne me paraît pas violent simplement dire
que sur la bioéthique ça serait bien
qu'on ait un débat apaisé
c'est pas violent au diaconat mensonge
institutionnel non c'est pas violent
parce que c'est pas la réalité
donc il n'ya pas de violence dans mes
propos je reviens je n'accuse personne
de quoi que ce soit je dis simplement
que c'est une occasion manquée d'avoir
un débat approfondi sur un sujet
fondamental je reviens à la droite on le
sait votre prochain président sera
christian jacob qui n'a jamais joué
d'ailleurs les premiers rôles y fera le
job mais le job ce sont les douze
travaux d'hercule de chaque club
maintenant non le job c'est d'abord de
rassembler de rassembler dans
l'ouverture
voilà et on peut rassembler en sur un
noyau dur et d'avoir le noyau tellement
dans l'ouverture sur un noyau dur c'est
l'échec n'auront alors pas du tout la
première façon c'est de dire on se
rétrécit et puis on est vraiment entre
nous voilà
les premiers et les premiers de la
première heure ou bien de dire par
écouter ça fait quand même plusieurs
sept ans qu'on est un échec on a perdu
deux élections présidentielle la
deuxième on n'a même pas été au deuxième
tour et ici on n'était pas dans notre
projet dans notre attitude d'un autre
façon de faire en rapport avec ce
qu'attendent les français
on n'a jamais raison contre le peuple
quand le peuple vous désavouer plusieurs
fois de suite ça veut dire qu'il faut
effectivement garder ses valeurs celles
valeur c'est c'est quelque chose vous
attendez mais que le programme et le
projet change le remède miracle
le remède miracle c'est aussi le change
merci des visages et des âges il faut
consulter votre changement alors vous
êtes par intérim vous partez ah ben je
m'en vais oui et je ne réclame aucun
poste de responsabilité au niveau
national féclaz je pense qu'une nouvelle
génération de reprendre le rôle merci
jean leonetti merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin sur europe 1
[Musique]